we have a distinguished speaker with us
today for our luncheon doctor art Laffer
is founder and chairman of laugher
associates and was a member of President
Reagan's economic policy advisory board
for both of Reagan's two terms he also
advised Prime Minister Margaret Thatcher
on fiscal policy in the UK during the
1980s he has been a faculty member at
the University of Chicago University of
Southern California and Pepperdine
University he is probably best known for
the Laffer curve and economics
illustration of the theory that there
exists some tax rate between 0% and a
hundred percent that will result in
maximum tax revenue for governments we
need to constantly remind politicians of
the Laffer curve he is the author and
co-author of many books and newspaper
articles he received a BA in economics
from Yale University and his MBA and PhD
in economics from Stanford please
welcome dr. art Laffer
you need it even after following you
thank you very much India but even after
following you I have to lower the
microphone it's not fair
the I tell the story that the one thing
nice about being on the faculty at the
University of Chicago was whenever I
followed Milton Friedman to the podium I
actually could raise the microphone no I
still have opportunities to do that I'm
whenever I debate Bob Rice could also
raise the microphone but the the
difference being Milton Friedman and Bob
Rice is I actually looked up to Milton
Friedman
I'm gonna have some fun with you today
we're gonna discuss a little politics
and economics if that's all right and
haven't have a little fun with it I do
have one thing I have a Hillsdale
connection other than Larry I have a
Hillsdale collection that connections is
my number six we have six children my
wife and I and my number six the number
of last one I finally got all six of
them married off that is a big deal she
married into a Hillsdale family now her
husband isn't the only one in the family
who didn't go to Hillsdale and I'll tell
you that story he's sorta cool I mean
you know um if you've had a large family
and you know you have in-laws you know
if you have six kids you have six
in-laws sometimes more but that's not
happened yet not about two but you know
it you love your kids unconditionally
you don't love your in-laws
unconditionally but this one I read
Larry if I can tell you his name is John
Lindsey he graduated from college he
enlisted in the army enlisted know AF
ROTC or any of that stuff he enlisted
he's from southern Michigan Michigan
family southern Michigan they they came
through after his enlistment they have
the bus that goes through all little
towns for all the kids of the listed
they they they go up to Lansing there
once a month the army gives the big
standardized test for all the kids and
the announcement at the end of the test
was John Lindsey John Lindsey is there
John Lindsey here and he he raised it in
you've got the highest test score of
anyone who's ever taken this test you
get your choice of services so he chose
to go into Special Forces so he is a
green beret
he served seven years he's just out in
this December he's had four missions to
the Middle East so no you remember I'm a
father
Oh
you ain't heard nothing yet well you
know can you imagine this is my you know
I always do the prayers before lunch you
know but I don't need to do them anymore
I've had my prayer even through he's a
Yale grad know I'm healing my father was
a Yalie both my brothers were jelly's my
nieces nephews my daughter I mean we're
a Yale family what's the chance of that
happening not only is he a li he's a
right winger there hasn't been a Yale
right when you were since Bill Buckley
died and he believes in God and loves my
daughter Lord I'm ready to be taken but
that they just got back from their
honeymoon so that's all in two weeks
they've been married but that's my
connection Larry with with them he'll
steal in this episode no I'm gonna have
some fun with you also I'm going to talk
to you a little bit about the politics
of what's going on and also the
economics of what's going on but I'm
gonna mix the two a little bit up and
try to be relevant as to where the sort
of the economic divide is occurring
amongst the political factions in the US
and I just finished a book called the
wealth of states and I want to go
through one chapter there I I call it
the fall from grace but this is the
political battle that is going on in
state and local government gee you all
think of politics as being the debate up
there with all 74,000 of them up in the
podium and whatever it's not politics
bubbles up from the bottom politics is
not driven by presidential candidates
it's driven by rank and file and what's
going on in the states and let me if I
can't take it through this one chapter
because it's sort of fun what I did was
I took the 11 states that have
introduced the personal income tax in
the last 60 years here in the United
States okay they've been 11 states back
70 years ago there there were 20 states
with no income tax today there
nine all right eleven states have
introduced the income tax and the first
one was in 1961 West Virginia you all
know West Virginia normal neat state
then of course you had the last one was
Connecticut Lowell Weicker another yaly
then you had Rhode Island was in there
Maine uh not only Rhode Island Maine
they've adopted income tax but you have
New Jersey I told you about West
Virginia you have also have Pennsylvania
you have Illinois Ohio Michigan Nebraska
Indiana you know normal states so what I
did in this and let me take you through
what I did in this just to give you a
flavor of the battle because this is the
battleground if you look at all of those
eleven states what I did is I took all
of the 11 states and I looked at their
economic metrics prior to their
introducing the income tax alright I
looked at their population relative of
their other 39 states I looked at their
employment their labor force their gross
state product yes I even went to their
state and local tax revenues relative to
the other 39 states that didn't have a
change you follow Andrew now they all
did it in different years so we have to
look at at different times different
places and all that but I took the
economic metrics of each of these states
before they put in the income tax and
then I took the last couple of years and
looked at those same economic metrics
and see how they did it's sort of
straightforward didn't eat real
complications that Larry Gatlin says it
ain't rocket surgery
and if you look at these 11 states I'm
gonna shock you a little bit each and
every one of those 11 states not one
exception has declined in each and every
metric relative to the rest of the
nation not one exception they all have a
lower percentage of u.s. population all
over the lower percentage of US labor
for its US employment you u.s. Gross
State product and also they have a lower
percentage of state and local tax
revenues every single one of them and
some of them have a lot less and when I
say a lot less I mean a lot less you
guys come from Michigan you know I'll
take you through Michigan what was his
name where Romney was that what it was
it was daddy Romney not Mitt Romney I
didn't know the difference but George
Romney put in the income tax and in
Michigan as you know Detroit City put on
a tax on profits within the city limits
global profits you know if you look at
that Michigan in the three years prior
to introducing the income tax was 5.2
percent of the u.s. economy today
Michigan is 2.7 percent of the US
economy that is a collapse when I was a
kid being raised in Cleveland I was born
in Youngstown Drazen Cleveland I'll take
you through Ohio a little bit too we
used to go to Detroit for vacation yeah
it's true
Detroit was the Paris of North America
the train station look like the Taj
Mahal I mean I don't know if any of you
remember those days it was spectacular
city in 1950 Detroit had a population of
1.8 five million today Detroit has a
population of six hundred and eighty
thousand that is a collapse Ohio my home
state I go back there my I was born in
Youngstown my mom and dad were both born
raised in Northeast know how all four my
grandparents are born raising
Northeastern Ohio seven out of meeting
my great-grandparents weren't you know
we've been there from the 1820s I go
back to visible on my rose I go to
Lakeview Cemetery and visit them all and
then then I wander through the city
there in Cleveland and see and if you
it's like a bomb hit it boarded up
windows people walking around with brown
paper bags and then you see these two
shining citizens of modern civilization
Cleveland State University which I
always put a little parentheses sick
after that there's no education going on
and Cleveland believe me when I tell you
and the other ones the Cleveland Clinic
what's with this here you have this bond
out city this horrible place and these
two signals shining bright beautiful
building with shining lights every
they're both 501 C 3 s tax-exempt
organizations tax-exempt organizations
always thrive best in high tax
environments it's incredible I mean you
look at some of the others I can take
you through that I mean but the one I
want to do with you just for a split
second now go into the u.s. because this
is the battleground and I'm going to
take you through the rest of the sphere
because this is what we're doing in our
federal level the state I love most of
all is New Jersey in 1965 now let me
just do this with you
in 1965 New Jersey had neither an income
tax nor a sales tax
neither one neither an income tax nor a
sales tax one of the fastest growing
states in the nation people from
everywhere moving in there and a
balanced budget eight years ago seven
years ago when my student was governor
of the state a guy named John Corzine he
was in my class at the University of
Chicago class
and by the way just in full disclosure
a C student
and after the disclosures of MF Global
and all that I'm not even sure you're in
the C New Jersey at highest property
taxes highest sales tax desire C income
tax of it everyone was leaving us like
rats off a sinking ship it was the
slowest growing state and they had a
huge budget deficit how do they do that
I mean when you look at this what's
going on and you know the point is it
really simple you can't balance a budget
on the taps back so the unemployed are
people who leave your state you can't
balance the budget on the backs of
people who've lost all their income you
really need economic growth to be able
to get any of this stuff going
I mean West Virginia you can't make us
put state poorer than West Virginia you
can't just put in an income tax and
three more teeth fall out just teasing
with him
just joking if you know how many of mine
are implants you'd understand I'm from
Eastern Ohio - yeah but it's me now
let's take ourselves back for a minute
let's take ourselves back for a minute
into the debates and the Capitals these
states and governor you know the debates
that go on in those capitals here we are
back in the debates of the 11 states and
we're listening to both sides and we
hear now you know what the one side
would say that the art Laffer side would
say oh you can't raise the income tax
you got to not do that you'll stop
growth output employment production
profits enterprise we need free
enterprise of stuff you hear what would
the other side say I mean what are you
that I guys say we need the money we
need the money our schools our highways
our police our fire I mean give me a
break laugher don't you hate these
public services the kids the poor kids I
mean we need to do these programs that's
what you'd hear so I understood the
debate they both are sort of logical in
their own constructs so in this study I
what I did was I went back in the three
years prior to them putting in the
income tax what was the level of the
provision of public services in these 11
states we have all the data we have the
full-time equivalent employees
population in every single endeavor of
state and local government we got all
those numbers school and all that stuff
we have input data on everything and we
have some external measures on some of
these things too we have the Department
of Education measuring of the
standardized tests of all the schools
fourth grade eighth grade English math
you know we have all those course we
have highway measurement by the reason
foundation you know we have all sorts of
objective external measures of the
quality of services and we have internal
measures of the application of services
to these states so what I did was I went
and through all the major areas
especially schools because schools are
the key issue here I mean 55 percent of
state and local governments are
employment are devoted towards schools
45% - all the other activities so I went
through and got all these measures
reached 11 states and compare them to
the other 39 states that didn't
introduce income tax you want to guess
if you look at these of the 11 states
three states Agri improves the provision
of their public services they did and
eight states were worse in the provision
of public services the three states that
improved were better by a tiny amount of
the eight states that were worth five of
them dropped by huge amounts I mean when
you look at this they don't even get the
results they promised I mean this is
where it is that's the chapter fall from
grace and the rest of the book I go
through lots of others comparing
California Texas that's a twenty three
thousand word chapter so I go through a
little details in that but you can go
through all this I mean I looked at the
the nine members of the of the Lord of
the Rings versus the nine members of the
Nazgul that my grandchildren gave me
that title with the nine states that
don't have an income tax on United
States that have the highest income tax
comparing you know the nine states with
no earned income tax the bejeebers out
of the nine states with the highest
income to actually every year for the
last 50 years this is the battleground
this is where we are today this is what
the national debate is all about
I'm going to take you a little bit more
but it's all about the role of
incentives and it is
what type of incentives are imposed in
economics you know tell me the answers
here I mean if you tax people who work
and you pay people who don't work do I
need to say the next sentence yeah duh
you're gonna get a lot of people not
working if you tax rich people and give
them money to poor people you're gonna
get lots and lots of poor people and no
rich people if you have two locations a
and B if you raise taxes and being you
lower man a producers manufacturers and
people are gonna move from two I mean
it's pretty straight for that's the
debate you know you look at some of this
stuff on redistribution you read Piketty
you read some of these other guys and
these are very attractive very
interesting it got the very good accent
and I love his that accent it's
wonderful the way you speak but you know
you look at picketing in capitalism in
their huge book the I mean but your
redistribution isn't difficult and let
me just take it through with it
redistribution the theorem and this is
math it's not Republican it's not
Democrat it's not liberal it's not
conservative it's not left me it's not
right-wing it's economics economics is
math and you shouldn't come to a
different answer just because you're
short or tall because you're liberal or
conservative
you really shouldn't when you
redistribute income you'll always take
from someone who makes a little bit more
and you give it to someone who makes a
little bit less isn't that what
redistribution is all about by taking
something from the people who have a
little bit more i they lose the
incentives to produce as much as they
did before and they're going to produce
a little bit less than they otherwise
would have produced symmetrically if you
give that to someone who makes a little
bit less that person finds an
alternative source of income other than
working and that person too is going to
work less the theorem is and it's math
whenever you redistribute income you
reduced to income that's math that
doesn't mean you don't do it but that
means you understand the consequences
your actions and the more you
redistribute little bigger the drop in
income will be and in the limiting case
in the limiting case if you have a
hundred percent redistribution of income
you will get zero income I mean let me
take you through this just quickly if I
can a hundred percent redistribution of
income means that everyone who works if
you make above the average income
they're gonna tax you a hundred percent
of the excess anyone who makes below the
average income
they'll subsidize them up to the average
income that is a complete redistribution
of income now if you do that you know
everyone's going to be equal now if you
actually did that if you actually taxed
everyone who made both they have average
income a hundred percent of the excess
and subsidized everyone who made below
the average income up to the average
income I will stipulate today councilor
everyone will be equal and that will be
at zero there will be no income and
that's the battleground today stimulus
spending
I mean stimulus spending what is the
logic here if we had Larry Summers here
today oh god I was I would I was just
with him over in Ukraine at the altar
conference which by the way is it's not
funny but it is very funny the altar
conference is now held in Kiev because
if you'll remember y'all tough was the
Ukrainian conference held in Ukraine
having me and the Crimea that it's now
held in the but the logic behind Larry
Summers thing is if you if you give a
kid I think if you give someone six
hundred bucks the government writes them
a check for six hundred bucks they're
gonna spend more than they otherwise
would have spent pretty clear anyone
disagree with that I don't disagree with
it and if they spend more than the
otherwise would have spent that will
create jobs output employment true those
people have higher incomes and the
otherwise would have had that's true
they'll spend more and there'll be this
cascading effect of the system then a
transfer recipient will spend more than
he or she otherwise would have spent
those that'll create jobs they'll spend
more and they'll be this cascading
effect of the system and that'll lift
the economy up by the bootstraps any of
you sort of a little nerdy here the
total increase in income coming from
this cascading effect that you add up
together the total effect is what we
call the multiplier and it's one over
one minus the marginal propensity to
consume if any of you remember your econ
10 class and that's sort of what it is
and with that Larry Summers goes and
sits down that's the whole logic
underlying both w's and Obama's stimulus
packages that's it you go and read a
Bernstein and Romer that's all they said
was here's the multiplier here's what it
is you give them the money they'll spend
more than the other ones would and
that's how you lift the economy up by
the bootstraps you know as far as they
went they're right they are right that's
nothing but unfortunately it's not the
whole truth you know the Tooth Fairy no
longer works at the US Treasury or for
you Brits I'll say father Christmas
doesn't work there right there it
doesn't the Treasury doesn't create
resources the Treasury redistributes
resources you know the Treasury for
every dollar they spend they have to
take it from someone else if you have a
hundred apples and the government spends
ten of those apples someone loses nine
as separate losses ten apples it's as
simple as that
the government redistributes income it
doesn't so therefore for the transfer
payer for the transfer recipient Larry
Summers is right but for the transfer
payer for the guy who actually who pays
those people they're transfers that
person will have less money than he or
she otherwise would have had that person
in turn will spend less than he or she
otherwise would have spent there'll be a
cascading effect on the other side in
exactly the opposite direction if any of
you remember your economics and again
forgive me for being a little bit
academic with you but if you sum the
Slutsky equation is in an economy the
income effects always sum to zero for
every transfer recipient who has a
positive income effect there's a
transfer payer who has a negative income
effect and they always some deserve the
stimulus to the transfer recipients is
exactly offset by the D stimulus from
the transfer payers thus there is no
stimulus and stimulus spending
now while the income effects always sum
to zero
let me tell you the substitution effects
don't and I had the worst time with
senator Nelson from Wisconsin long time
ago trying to explain this to him I I
was on the boat
it is 1974 with Jerry Ford's whip
inflation tax rebate thing that was
going on then I every many of you
remember that God long ago but I was
trying trying to explain to them the
substitution effects and I would hurt
the economy and I I was on with Gardner
Ackley and and Paul McCracken and one
other I forget who it was but and they
were all in favor of the stimulus and I
was of course opposed to it and I was
trying to explain the substitution
effect to senator Nelson I just couldn't
get in finally I said senator Nelson if
these other three guys are are correct
what is wrong with you why would you
only do 600 bucks I mean don't you want
a booming economy why stop at 600 let's
make it six thousand let's do 60,000
let's do six million let's do a hundred
percent of GNP let's have a stimulus
program equal to a hundred percent of
GNP so everyone who works it produces
receives nothing and all those who don't
work and don't produce receive
everything senator what do you honestly
think would happen to output and of
course the answers would go to zero
stimulus spending is why we have the
Great Recession that is exactly the
reason why it's why we had the Great
Depression I went through a little bit
at the table do you realize in 1930
before we put in a smooth Hawley Tariff
the highest marginal income tax was 25
percent we had one of the freest trade
countries then we passed smoot-hawley
the biggest tax increase on traded
products that kind of me spin him what
does our guy Herbert Hoover do he raises
the highest marginal income tax rate in
the United States from 25% to 63% and
collapses the brackets by the way puts
in the gift tax estate tax
he pad does all the excise taxes
corporate tax he raises I mean it's
amazing and then of course we went way
down on the depression and then of
course he lost the election to Roosevelt
I won't go through the bank holiday Act
but then Roosevelt gets in and in 35 he
was having a little problem so he
decided to raise tax a little bit
further he raises the income tax from
63% to 79 out to 83 percent all right he
raised the estate
except a 90% that makes me want to work
really hard for my grandkids there he go
does the reason we had the longest
deepest depression in world history was
because our tax increases throughout
that period you read any of the studies
in the Great Depression they don't
mention taxes once it's not mentions
money supply this or something else that
it's all taxes and it's all taxes on
traded products and work on that you
know that's the issue coming here
redistribution taxes taxes on the rich
you know every single time we've raised
the highest marginal income tax rate in
this country other than the first time
I'll concede when we instituted the
income tax in 1913 and we put the
highest rate up to 7 percent I will
stipulate today that rich people pay
more in taxes at 7 percent than they did
at 0 ok I'll concede I Paul Krugman you
got me on that one
but every other time every other time
you know when we raised the taxes up to
77 percent by 1919 guess what happened
to tax revenues from the highest 1% of
income earners we have those data
everyone has these days what happened to
tax revenues as a share of GDP
dammit and then what happened during the
roaring 20s when we cut the highest rate
from 77% down to 25% tax revenue now
think of that we went from 77 to 25
that's a cutting to less than a third of
what it had been the exclusive tax rate
on the rich we took it to a third of
what it was and tax revenues as a share
of GDP went through the ceiling and then
the depression which I took you in the
tax numbers there what happened to tax
revenues from the top 1% of income
earners and then you get the Kennedy tax
cuts we dropped the highest rate from 91
percent to 70 percent we put in the
investments tax credit accelerated
depreciation Kennedy round tariff
negotiation we dropped the corporate tax
all of that what happened to tax
revenues from the top one percent of
income earners we had a boom and tax
revenues from the top one percent went
through the ceiling and then what
happened with the four stooges Johnson
Nixon Ford and Carter
the largest assemblage of bipartisan
ignorant probably ever put on planet
Earth tax revenues from the top 1% of
income earners I went down and then
excuse me I've I'll be still my heart to
say molarity water just joking and then
the skies cleared the clouds parted the
Sun shone forth on America the fields
they turned green the animals multiplied
and the trees blossom in the fruit boy
and the and and the children danced in
the streets and mean it was just and
Reagan was nominated and then elected
let me take it to the taxes you're right
I don't know if this is a good tax cut
or not but we dropped the highest
marginal income tax rate from 70% to 28%
that okay was it that wasn't too bad
anything that flew we cut its taxes any
of the dug holes we've cut its taxes if
it's sat there we cut its taxes too
there wasn't a tax we didn't write about
where is that tax we can cut we went
running around in 1980 tax revenues from
the top 1% of income earners as a share
of GDP accounted for 1.5 percent of GDP
in other words you take the top 1% of
income earners we have all of them we
have all their tax returns we take all
the taxes they paid divided by GDP and
it comes out one and a half percent of
GDP and then you get this progression in
2005 before the big change in direction
tax revenues as a share of GDP were up
to 3.2 percent of GDP way more than
doubled now every other single tax
bracket declined but the taxes on the
rich didn't decline you go back and read
Coolidge's speeches on why you have to
cut taxes on the rich because they can
get around them they can hire lawyers
accountants deferred income specialists
they can hire congressmen senators I
mean come on when you see a group of
people hanging with Obama don't think
for a moment this is a group of street
people trying to explain to him what
it's like being poor
these are Goldman Sachs people switching
from the Treasury to Goldman Sachs and
back I mean you know these people have
the ways and the means to change their
taxes and that's what if you make your
tax system fair it'll work don't this is
the battleground and this is the battler
not one single Republican candidate is
is argue for any higher tax rates in
fact they all are going for low number
than five of them I think are arguing
for complete flat tax I mean they really
are I've been working with every single
one of them except for Santorum I don't
know Santorum personally although he's
pretty good on his tax plan I'll be be
honest with you but I've worked with all
of them spent a lot of time on every one
of these Republican candidates is
marching to the hymnal and they really
are their model is low rate broad-based
flat tax spending restraint government
spending his taxation sound money and
they didn't go through sound money with
you but I could just as well spend the
whole time on that low rate broad-based
flat tax spending restraints sound money
free trade there are some things we do
better than foreigners and there's some
things foreigners do better than we do
we and they would be foolish to the
extreme if we didn't sell them those
products we make better than native in
exchange for those products they make
better than we do it's win-win it's
called David Ricardo the gains from
trade comparative advantage and lastly
minimal law regulations you know we
can't wake up in the morning and decide
which side of the road we're going to
drive on today we all know that come on
you need regulations you need a lot of
them but you want to make sure you look
at the specific problem at hand and
direct the regulations of that and not
go beyond that and create a lot of
collateral damage in the overall economy
that's all you do five things you need
low rate broad-based flat tax spending
restraint sound money free trade and
minimal regulations then get the hell
out of the way and let the economy solve
itself
I love to I'd love to do my paraphrase
didn't even remember Charlton Heston in
the Planet of the Apes if you watch it's
one of my favorite movies
but what's specially when one of the
monkeys grabbed him there and it's mine
I like to use to to my friends The
Economist's of the other ilk my line is
keep your stinking paws off my economy
you dirty lever all of Keynesian I'm
just joking but the two differences in
philosophies are a really very
fundamental one is you know what I do is
I look at the economy and I'm an
awestruck I don't know how this meal got
put together and how all of you with all
the clothes in the meeting the building
the planes and all it's amazing how the
economy works to produce all these
products I sit in awe watching this
economy you know I believe that I should
almost worship at the economy it's so
wonderful and just it's the natural
healing powers of nature my motto is
primum non nocere first of all make sure
you don't do any harm the second one is
if something's going wrong it's bhisma
to Catterick Natori which is the healing
power of each my friends on the other
side of the aisle they always believe
they studied the economy so they can
change it so they can sit there and put
their hands on the dials and try to
manipulate that is where the philosophy
is going today we are winning and I want
to tell you we're not only winning we're
winning big time
if you look at the state legislatures
today Republicans pro-growth of the ten
tax cutting governors in the United
States all ten won re-election this last
election of the seven tax increasing
governors in the United States for lost
their seats all right and they did
Massachusetts Maryland Illinois and
unfortunately for a Republican Corbett
it was Pennsylvania lost all right the
other three one Jerry Brown one
mark Dayton one that's true and so did
O'Malley win that I mean not o'malley of
the Malloy so did Malloy win but look
what happened Jerry Brown lost his super
majority in both the House and the
Senate simply in the Senate and in in
Minnesota we took the house in Minnesota
I mean if you look at this the
Republicans now have 31
governors they control 31 state
legislatures and I include Nebraska in
that I know you're not partisan you're
agnostic no you're not you're just one
of us your ass but it's true I mean we
have 31 state like we owned the pole the
minor leagues we own all the the the
bollocky I mean we own all the future
players we really do it's amazing if you
look at the house us house we control
more seats today than at any time since
1928 this house is going to remain
Republican for the at least the next 20
years there's no way anyone's going to
undo the Republicans there if we slip it
through in the Senate now in the Senate
we before the last election it was 45
Republicans 55 Democrats I'm including
the two independents there angus king
and bernie sanders the yeah i include
them as democrats it was 45 55 and we
took picked up nine seats we should have
picked up 10 but everyone got to would
see about it on Virginia but we should
have won Virginia too but we picked up
nine now it's 54 Republicans versus 46
Democrats and and and independents there
and you never know when some of those
independents some of those Democrats are
thinking about switching and they are
we'll see how it goes if the Republicans
win the Senate this next election in
2016 will have the Senate for the next
20 years too I mean because then all of
a sudden the odds come back into our
favor very dramatically you know we have
the governors we have this legislators
we have a house and we have Senate or
missing one seat we're missing one seat
and I can tell you knowing all these
candidates you are seeing the best
process imaginable going on there's
nothing like good competition for
collisions in the arena to try their
ideas out and filter them out and get
the best one to be our running Kennedy
my guess is that we're going to get a
great candidate coming out of this I
think all these candidates are really
highly qualified every single one of
them and I I do know them all and I've
known them all for a long time they're
all highly qualified and whichever one
is selected that
we'll have honed his or her message very
very well and would be a formidable
candidate I don't think it's Hillary's
time and I don't mean Hillary because of
her personally I think that view of
economics time has passed Bernie Sanders
and Hillary just aren't with this
revolution they they aren't you know
they're fine people and all that but
it's not their day it's our day and
you're gonna see a Republican victory in
2016
you're gonna see a Republican House
Senate and presidency in 2017 you're
gonna see a supply-side revolution
that's gonna make the Reagan Revolution
look like kids play my view of the world
I've been to this barbecue before and I
have I was there in the 70s with Reagan
I was there in the late 60s with Reagan
the only reason I was with Reagan as my
godfather was his best friend so that
always I've always loved privilege
earning something is just not nearly as
much fun as being given it but and I'm
just gonna tell you I used to tease the
real president and forgive me on this I
used to tease him a little bit and how
you say sir you know it's my
professional judgment as a professor as
an academic as a as an economist that
you sir truly are a certifiable genius
I said but you know syrup some of my
colleagues at the University don't
really concur in my assessment of your
intellectual acumen thank you so my
colleagues don't think you're very
bright at all but the one thing my
colleagues and I do agree upon is you're
one unique characteristic is your
uncanny ability to select your four
predecessors
anyone following the heels of Johnson
Nixon Ford and Carter just can't look
bad and it's true it is true you know if
Reagan had been elected in 1976 he would
not have been the Ronald Reagan you and
I loved he really wouldn't have been he
would have been a very different
president and one that would have been
much less appealing to all of us today
in all honesty it took Jimmy Carter to
create a Ronald Reagan and in the same
breath that it took Jimmy Carter to
create Ronald Reagan you cannot believe
the great president who's going to
follow Barack Obama thank you
why do questions
thank you I can't tell you how much I
love all of you here I mean it's just
you guys make it so much fun and it's
just wonderful and thank you all for
being here and thank you all for
supporting Hillsdale it's just really
neat that you do that any questions I
can't see beyond the first row so if
there is one back there someone I do
look good but I don't see I wasn't going
to do this let me I can't answer the
question what's the quest what tax rate
would you make for the optimal tax like
is that pretty short answer I did do one
person's tax plan that I did from
beginning to end Jerry Brown when Jerry
Brown ran for president in 1992 I did
his whole tax plan a hundred percent no
changes in it let me take you through
what I did if you look at incentives in
this world incentives if you know what
dominate my thinking there are two types
of incentives there positive incentives
and negative incentives by way of
illustration if you beat a dog you know
where the dog won't be but you have no
idea where the dog will be it's gonna
run like hell but you don't
which duration write negative incentives
tell you what not to do all right
don't put your hand on the hot stove
positive incentive to tell you what to
do about the other thing and if you feed
the dog you know exactly what that dog
will be at feeding time right breaking
it at the food so what you have to do is
take government policies and look at
them in terms of negative and positive
incentive positive incentives taxes are
negative incentive why do we tax feeders
on the freeway to get them to stop
speeding why do we tax cigarettes to get
people to stop smoking why do we talk
tax income earners employers and profit
makers now we don't do that to get them
to stop employing to stop making income
and to stop having profits we do that
recognizing the damage of taxes but we
do it to get the requisite revenues by
the least harmful method possible so
what you want to do is collect your
taxes in the least damaging fashion and
spend it the most positive fashion what
I did with Jerry Brown is what you want
to have is the lowest possible tax rate
on the broadest possible tax base so you
provide people with the least incentives
to evade avoid or otherwise not report
taxable income and you give them the
least place to which they can hide their
income and avoid paying taxes what we
did on that was we got rid of all
federal taxes with Jerry's plan all got
rid of the personal income tax out of
here got rid of the corporate tax gone
we got rid of Medicare Medicaid taxed we
got rid of all payroll taxes both
employer and employee we got rid of
excise taxes we got rid of tariffs we
got rid of capital gains tax we got rid
of the unearned income tax we got rid of
the death tax we got rid of all those
taxes what a little group we left we
left send taxes because the purpose of a
sin tax really is not so much to raise
revenues as it is to change behavior I
used to joke that we Americans don't
like drunk people smoking while we shoot
each other
okay but if you're replaced all federal
taxes with two flat rate taxes one on
business net sales and when a person
alone and just income from the first
dollar to the last Auto you can match
all federal revenues with our twelve
percent flat tax at full employment can
you imagine what this country would look
like if we had two flat taxes one on
business net sales call it value-added
if you want to I know you guys don't
like the word but it's value-added call
it value-added and personal own adjusted
gross income from the first dollar to
the last can you imagine if we had two
taxes twelve percent of each of those
what this country would look like in
about four minutes we'd be selling cars
in the central China
and we'd have a balanced budget we'd
everyone off welfare we'd have the
growth economy of all growth economies I
mean you know and what you gotta make
sure these candidates don't do is put
positive programs in negative plans you
should never have a child tax credit
never have an earned income tax right
don't do that that's putting a positive
system inside a negative system which
always gonna nerd a damaged if you want
to help people with kids right i'ma
check here's your check for your kids
there are some people who don't file
taxes who still have kids you want to
put them outside the system but it's
also destroys all the incentives the
structure of the system so always make
sure you separate positive incentives
and negative incentives and these are
the ones I talk to each of the
candidates about in the Senate of
structure and how to go about doing that
does that I hope that answers your
question
but how are you going to give voters out
to make sure they because yeah you know
I'm not the political rove but but let
me just say that we had this problem in
1982 I mean 80 as well
we had Jimmy Carter not only do we have
Jimmy Carter who was an incumbent
Democratic president with all the power
of the incumbency for press and
everything else Reagan also did win the
Republican primary which he'd lost in 76
but he did win it but one of the
candidates was so offended by Reagan
being the dumb person he was they called
him an amiable dunce if you remember and
if you remember that stuff they said
here's a man who speaks words other
people right he's a he's a dangerous
cowboy you know if you go to the Reagan
ranch and look at the little video that
I got him to put in there of all the
people a lot of them Republicans pass
him John Anderson was so offended by
Reagan winning the nomination he decided
to run as an independent against us
coming into that election you know it
wasn't clear we're gonna win and then
all of us in we swept the place that is
exactly what's going to happen once
again there is no one out there no one
who enjoys getting handouts Jack Kennedy
put it so perfectly when he said the
best form of welfare is still a good
high paying job and when Jack Kennedy
put it well and I you know I'm a Kennedy
Democrat in the 60s it became a Reagan
Republican and you know when Kennedy
said that no American has ever made
better off by pulling a fellow American
down and every American is better off if
any one American is made better off and
then he said the next line which we sigh
I stolen we use in the campaign is a
rising tide it raises all boats and that
is what the pro-growth tax spending
agenda monetary policy that I went
through the five will do we will create
Chinese growth rates here for years to
come no one remembers
but the growth rates were like in 83 and
84 no one remembers what the growth
rates were like in 63 64 when Kennedy
did exactly the same thing I mean if you
go back to the 20s the Roaring Twenties
with Coolidge and Harding massive growth
rates 6 7 8 9 percent annualized growth
rates quarter by I mean it was amazing
we need that now more than ever and
that's how we convince them by telling
them the truth we're gonna create jobs
and growth and output I'm sorry you're
the boss professor okay well then I will
then I won't tell you that but I will
tell you the that good thing if you get
a chance
Business Week Bloomberg just celebrated
its 85th anniversary and they did 85
disruptive events in their history one
of which was that dinner that dinner was
with Jude Winooski who's now since
passed he wrote the book the way the
world works one of my best friends ever
it included a guy named Don Rumsfeld who
was in chief of staff for President Ford
and included my classmate one of my
dearest friends Dick Cheney if you go
back to the if you guys got computers I
don't have a computer but I have people
who do but out him if you look up on the
website of Bloomberg and look up the
dinner in 1974 we did a reenactment of
that dinner you will love it with rummy
myself and dick don't you'll find it a
hoot but so there I'll let all of you to
go back look it up in Bloomberg and
you'll find it you really enjoy it I
mean you don't find two finer people on
earth than Don Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney
I don't believe
is that go ahead the question is what is
the real unemployment rate and I'm gonna
put it in a different way than your
question if I may just slightly twist a
little bit what I like to do is what is
the correct market indicator for
employment okay as you know the
unemployment rate official is down to 5%
but we've had a very big drop in the
participation rate and that means that a
lot of the people are leaving the
unemployment rolls and they're leaving
the labor force they're not getting a
job the correct thing to look at at
least in a gross sense that I do is I
look at total US employment as a
percentage of adult population so that's
the number I look at now in the end of
2000 and Clinton's last year in office
that number peaked and at sixty four
point seven percent during the Great
Recession that number came puple up up
and up and up and up and up top down to
W and Obama it's you know this is I'm
sorry to say it's bipartisan error but
through both Obama and W it tumbled
dramatically down to about fifty eight
point three four percent was it's very
very low that it last set for just a
little bit time but it's been sitting
there now for almost eight years just
right at that level it's now up to fifty
nine point two percent we are losing
about 14 million people years every year
of employment in this country and it's
cumulative employment is a precious
natural resource that is not renewable
once you lose it you've lost it
another way of looking at your number
that now this does not take into account
average
or part-time full-time for but those are
very very small adjustments but it does
include participation rates and the
unemployment rate which is what you
should do all right the other way I look
at it as I look at GDP which is total
production of goods and services in the
United States
I do the trend from 1947 to the present
and if you look at that how far are we
off let's say the last high if you look
at today versus the last year of
Clinton's administration we are about
three and a half trillion three point
eight trillion dollars off trend from
the Clinton end of the Clinton
administration that is atrocious
we are losing three and a half trillion
dollars worth of output real terms all
right every single year because of bad
economics there I mean that is the real
problem I hope that answers your
question now that's the last question
because I was expecting one question and
I prepared for it and and the one I was
expecting was all you guys are in
business and all of your conservatives
like investing and all that sort
so I took my supply-side model and
worked it up real carefully I took it to
the Nasdaq the American exchange and to
the New York Stock Exchange and I
thought someone for sure would ask me my
stock picks so what I did was I did the
analysis of all the stocks use and
supply-side economics and it's amazing 5
stocks popped out that are guaranteed to
triple guaranteed a triple if not more
in the next six months but no one asked